another one is an open source project
that Richard and I have been developing
to make it easy for data scientists and
data Engineers to run any python code on
the cloud
without much hassle
so why did we come up with this ID well
because we think that developing locally
is convenient right you have everything
sort of at your fingertips it's fast
there's lots of flexible flexibility but
it can be limiting right if you need to
run a job on bigger data or you need
maybe some big gpus or maybe you just
don't want to run along a batch job or
training job or whatever on your local
machine just so you can do something
else then you're kind of in a bind there
locally but the cloud on the other hand
has lots of capacity to run these kinds
of things but it's kind of annoying to
access
um there's first of all there's an
embarrassment of choices do you use
Virtual machines do you use like
kubernetes clusters you use lambdas
there's all these kind of options that
you have and even if you do make a
choice then there's
the infrastructure that you still need
to set up it's much better than running
a data center of course but still
there's many API calls or terraform
scripts or whatever it is that you want
to use to set up the infrastructure and
even then you you still don't have like
the local code and your local python
environment conda or people or whatever
it is that you use available on those
machines maybe you need to go build
containers
or stuff like that
and so what metal run does is it's an
open source tool that is that automates
all these aspects of running your python
code base on the cloud so it's it's
geared specifically towards Python and
um this stock will mostly discuss the uh
well the AWS uh Target but we also do
support Azure and kubernetes
the idea is this is not a service it's a
tool it's a it's a library that you can
just clip install
um so you bring your python code base
um you give matter one access to the
your AWS account and whether one kind of
does the rest
and so I'll
show you what that looks like
um
in this demo here
so here we have a if you look on the
left here in the uh in the kind of I
hope that's visible can make it a big
bigger
um where we have kind of a small uh
python code base
um the IDS there are multiple python
files here so this is just meant to the
the code base itself can certainly be
much bigger the the only thing what
we're intending to show here is that you
can it's this is not limited to just
running one script or one jupyter
notebook it's like we really Target
um
larger python code bases with
um a whole bunch of um like third-party
dependencies that you can have as well
here I've been using conda but we also
do support virtual amps and poetry
and so just to give a quick walk through
what is fairly simple code base does it
just calls this classify score function
which is in this file here which trains
a k nearest The nurburg Neighbors
classifier which Casper just talked
about and then splits a training Set uh
data sets in that it loads from
scikit-learn
uh which is a third-party dependency
here of this uh of this code base and
does some predict and returns some
training and test scores
so what it does is not very important
but we can run it and see that it works
um because I have my contact environment
here uh and it outputs some data now
suppose we want to
run this um run this classify score
function with all its dependencies on on
an AWS virtual machine
then we can use matter one to do that
pretty easily so let me just close this
uh what you need to do
um to get better one to work is as I
said just pip install it and give it
access to your AWS account and then you
write this in Python you write this sort
of specification or
function uh
you call run function to um to to tell
another one what you want to run and
where you want to run it
so I'm just going to get this started
because it can take a bit of time for
the
virtual machine on AWS to boot up I'll
show you the output later while I
explain
um what what this is saying so what do
we need to tell another one which is
well we need to tell it which python
function to run which here is classify
score as we did in the other Main
we also need to tell it what kind of
compute we want to Target
here we're saying we want an AWS virtual
machine which is called ec2 if you're
not familiar
and then we tell um what kind of compute
resources we need on the remote machine
so
um AWS itself or ec2 has a whole wide
range of virtual machines available and
they all have complicated code names
like G5 x large and then there's a whole
list that you then have to go figure out
to see you know does it set how many
CPUs does this thing have how much
memory does this thing have so another
one abstracts this all the way from you
and just allows you to say Okay I want
this many CPUs I want this memory this
much memory you can also specify gpus
and GPU memory
and then this um maybe somewhat
mysterious parameter here allows you to
access so-called spot instances spot
instances are virtual machines that AWS
makes available to you at a cheaper
price for a kind of excess capacity the
downside is that they can be interrupted
and they give you an estimate of how
high that Interruption chance is and
this is sort of the maximum Interruption
chance that you will be able to tolerate
if you set this to zero you will get a
so-called on-demand instances instance
which will not be interrupted
and finally what you need to tell
another one is what you want to remote
kind of deployment to look like uh and
here we're saying well I just want to
mirror my local environment and what
matter when we'll do that is look
um look at the environment in which this
function is running which in this case
will be a condo environment figure out
what's in it replicate that on the
remote side and also figure out what the
local code is that it needs and also
send that to the remote site so
hopefully by now it's done that
oh
it has not
that's unfortunate and the demo effect
of course let me
try that again and if I run out of time
then I will have to interrupt it
um
so what it's saying here now is uh
as I said it's mirroring the current
environment it's a detected that it's
running into a condo environment
it's figured out that there's no
existing instance running in my account
at the moment in which case it will try
to launch a new instance
um it does keep instances around for a
bit for virtual machines around for a
bit in case you kind of run
um the machines uh new jobs on existing
machines
so I think it's now actually
uh
managed to start it
yeah so it's launched the new instance
for the job
it tells you what kind of instance it is
the t2 medium it has two CPUs and four
gigabytes it tells you what it's going
to cost and what the eviction rate
chance is and then it runs to work on it
um
as you can see here it's done pulling a
Docker image you might wonder where is
this Docker image coming from well I I
run this job before and
because because it takes a long time to
build a Docker image you can take like a
special Good Conduct it takes for five
minutes so to speed up the demo
um uh I've built a Docker Image First
and matter when automatically caches
this and if there are no changes in your
contact environment then it will just
reuse that Docker image so it just now
needs to pull it to the to the virtual
machine to done run the function into it
uh I think I'll
let it do that and then just continue
with the
and come back to it afterwards to save
some time
so I showed you a run function there's
also some other uh uh API commands that
you can call from better one one is run
command so you can run a shell command
in an environment and there's also a run
map where it's basically like a parallel
map that can run a single function but
on a list of arguments and and will
allocate many machines
and then run those uh run that function
on those in parallel
let's sorry it did not meant to do that
so as I said we target AWS we also
Target Azure so you can also start Azure
VMS we also Target kubernetes and Google
kubernetes engine
uh here's some more info on that the
main website is matter run.io give us a
star or follow us on Twitter and I'll
I'll be available on the uh on the
Discord as well if you have any
questions
let's see oh yeah it has actually
finished so at least I I can prove that
it works
so here's the uh the output from the uh
from the remote run